this is going to continue to go on first
of all we are trying to make some
changes at the municipal level obviously
at the county level st. Louis County and
at the state level in fact in about an
hour I have a hearing on upping
upgrading our laws when it relates to
deadly force Missouri is one of the only
states in the nation that is not
addressing deadly force as defined by
the US Supreme Court so we're going to
have to make some changes and I think
this year we have bipartisan support to
do that and as it relates to people who
are in the streets who feel the injury
every single day who are protesting what
they are going to be looking for is
systemic changes not only in the
Ferguson Police Department but
throughout the region and throughout the
nation let me tell you an unarmed person
is killed every single day by a police
officer it is not right it should not be
condoned and frankly I am Telling You
Now on Sky News that there someone has
authorized it genocide of black men in
the United States and it's intolerable
for us to go to the United Nations or
any other entity throughout the world
and talk about human rights let's talk
about the human rights violations right
here in the United States first indeed
and of course you yourself experience
some of this when you took part of the
protests last year didn't you and you
were tear gassed what is it going to
take because when you read this report
is quite clear it isn't just about
change the top of the police system
there it's about changing the whole
system itself the entire system and
you're absolutely right right on my desk
where I'm talking to you from I have my
gas mask that I had to use when I was
tear gassed for three and a half hours
on August 11th but what we are going to
have to do one I am asking for the
resignation of the Chief of Police I am
also asking for the disbandment of the
Ferguson Police Department and the other
issue that needs to be addressed is this
is not isolated to just Ferguson there
are other entities police entities that
are out there who have also created an
environment where african-americans are
harassed and intimidated
what's most
concerning to me there are many things
in this report but I can't understand
for the life of me why there were 14
cases of people who were bitten by dogs
the police officers in first and aloud
dogs to bite innocent people and they
were all African American there is a
problem that exists and this is the veil
has been uncovered it has been lifted
and no longer can we sweep dust under
the rug it's not going to be tolerated
anymore camara has woken up